ah
[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a corresponsales el programa
que los lleva a dar una vuelta al mundo
a través de nuestra red de periodistas
soy herminia fernández por andrés
espinal rossi ha tenido dificultades
para encontrar voluntarios que quieran
ir al combate en ucrania el kremlin ha
tenido que recurrir a creativas formas
para atraerlos desde bonos en efectivo
hasta cupo para sus hijos en las
escuelas para encontrar más personas los
reclutadores también han visitado las
cárceles para pedir a los reclusos que
vayan a la guerra esto es un informe de
olivia vichot y nuestros compañeros de
france tú
desde que rusia lanzó su invasión a
ucrania hace seis meses el reclutamiento
de soldados se ha convertido en un gran
desafío en este fuero militar cerca de
moscú los oficiales del reclutamiento
están ocupados tendrás que hacer el
examen médico en casa murat sokólov
tiene 17 años y está ansioso por entrar
en las filas del ejército la operación
especial no te molesta
quiero proteger a mi país por más
peligroso que sea
estoy dispuesto a sacrificar mi vida por
mi país por mi patria
gatos abiertos
y registran
con el fin de atraer nuevos reclutas las
autoridades están ofreciendo a los
voluntarios grandes sumas de dinero
plazas especiales para sus hijos en las
escuelas rusas y terrenos también hay
muchos beneficios y bonificaciones
rusia no da números pero la inteligencia
de eeuu dice que entre 70.000 y 80.000
soldados rusos han muerto o han
resultado heridos desde el comienzo de
la guerra y necesitan ser reemplazados
por ahora
vladimir putin quiere evitar una
movilización general y eso es un alivio
para los jóvenes rusos con los que
hablamos no veo el punto no tiene
sentido quiero unirme no gracias
para mí la movilización general de rusia
simplemente no tiene sentido
para llenar los vacíos en la fuerza de
combate los reclutadores también han
estado visitando las prisiones rusas
para inscribir a los reclusos
prometiéndoles libertad y dinero
han pasado seis meses desde el inicio de
la guerra en ucrania la seguridad actual
en las áreas liberadas alrededor de kiev
hace posible las reuniones familiares
nuevamente la devastación de irving una
ciudad cercana a la capital que estaba
ocupada y destruida impedía que marín a
una mujer ucraniana que ha vivido en
londres durante 20 años se reencontrará
con su madre pero finalmente logró
hacerlo y para la fecha de su cumpleaños
aquí el informe de james andrew virgin
years y wazin dalí
ah ya acaba de cumplir 85 años a pesar
de la guerra su hija marina ha viajado
especialmente desde londres como cada
año para estar allí con sus dos hermanas
si fue importante para mí
fue una verdadera fiesta
marina creció en el ping se fue hace 24
años al reino unido se casó con un
francés y ahora trabaja en el instituto
ucraniano de londres la familia se ha
perdido uno de los cumpleaños mamá de
espectometría mi madre se está volviendo
bastante trajes por lo que era aún más
importante para nosotros reunirnos a
pesar de la guerra estar juntos y
sentirnos como una familia que
simplemente nos da fuerza y la sensación
de que superaremos esto aboca hundes
antes de partir en el tren hacia polonia
del reino unido marina quiere mostrar a
sus dos hijos el puente ir pin destruido
por donde parte de su familia cruzó el
río para huir de los rusos el 7 de marzo
pasado ese lugar se ha convertido en un
símbolo de la lucha de ucrania contra la
invasión rusa
ucrania se independizó cuando yo tenía
20 años ahora tengo 51 y he vivido todo
esto al igual que millones de otros
ucranianos es una historia definitoria
de nuestra vida program ya se está
convirtiendo en un país un país
verdaderamente independiente un país
verdaderamente europeo y está pagando un
precio muy alto
una lucha que marina quiere que sus
hijos que han crecido a miles de
kilómetros de distancia entiendan
de hecho estaba bastante preocupado de
pisar una mina terrestre así que siempre
estoy pendiente de ver dónde pisas
se siente bastante surrealista siempre
hemos vivido en londres desde que
nacimos pero definitivamente puedo
sentir que este es mi país hay un 70
harvest quería que tuvieran un recuerdo
fuerte sobre esto es un momento decisivo
para nosotros cuando regresa a londres
marina seguirá siendo campaña por la
independencia de su país ucrania
el chile se vive una de las crisis
habitacionales más duras en las últimas
décadas que se agravó por el estallido
social y la pandemia se calcula que hay
un déficit habitacional que afecta a
unas 600 mil personas que han buscado
otros lugares donde vivir entre ellos
los terrenos tomados ilegalmente esto es
un informe de patricia luna y álex plaza
nandi valladares vídeo desde hace más de
tres años en este campamento luego de
sufrir un robo en el lugar que alquilaba
decidió juntar dinero para construir su
propia casa en este asentamiento ilegal
el terreno donde habita se encuentra
frente a uno de los barrios más ricos de
santiago y muestra las grandes
desigualdades que perforan a la sociedad
chilena
me dijeron apenas estaban haciendo esto
aquí de tomarse los terrenos de aquí la
misma gente entonces dije no yo también
voy a ir porque porque siempre he sido
de allá yo esto estar ahí donde estaba
no estaba bien como nandy su hermana
magdalena también se instaló en el
campamento para estar cerca de su
familia llevan más de un año y medio
arreglando en su casa ambas viven con el
temor constante de ser desalojadas ya
que la municipalidad ha tratado de
expulsarlos varias veces de ahí una de
las muchas dificultades de vivir en una
toma ilegal la gente siempre piensa y
decir a ellos llegar intentaron y tienen
todo gratis pero no es así acá y hay
dificultades
si hace invierno se pasa frío si hay
verano se pasa calor acá de repente no
siempre tú podéis vivir tranquila a
pesar de que esto espacio una situación
que enfrentan muchos chilenos
inmigrantes extranjeros en un momento en
el país en que se agudiza una constante
crisis habitacional el aumento de
campamentos se ha incrementado un 74%
desde 2019 el porcentaje más alto en los
últimos 25 años se estima que más de 81
mil familias viven en asentamientos de
este tipo en todo el país
lo que tengo el hecho de a poquito
porque nos va a hacer más posible
tuviera poder terminarlo de una
terminaría de ver que me falta la mitad
este hecho
a mitad del cómputo de pizarreño que
antiguo en la otra mitad es con latas el
nuevo gobierno de gabriel boric ha
prometido crear más de 260 mil viviendas
sociales durante su mandato una cifra
muy ambiciosa pero todavía insuficiente
para un problema de vieja data que sigue
aumentando día a día en el país el
hambre en brasil había sido erradicada
en 2014 sin embargo vuelve a afectar a
los brasileños ya son 60 millones de las
víctimas de la inseguridad alimentaria
según el informe de la onu publicado el
pasado mes de julio recientemente
ocurrió un caso impactante en el
horizonte un niño de 11 años estaba tan
hambriento que llamó a la policía para
pedir ayuda el hambre que ya afecta a
una cuarta parte de la población promete
ser un tema central de la campaña de
elecciones presidenciales que acaba de
comenzar este es el informe de fanny lu
tea juliá culture y lisa believe
alrededor de los mercados de sao paulo
la capital económica del país la vida
tiene una rutina triste cada mañana más
y más personas sin hogar mujeres y niños
recorren la basura en busca de comida
marcia perdió su hogar hace unos meses
sólo come lo que encuentra aquí sobras
de comida a veces vencidas y en su bolso
solo hay huesos
es el
scouting
en brasil desde el inicio de la pandemia
el precio de la carne uno de los
alimentos que hace parte del consumo
diario de los brasileños aumentó casi un
40% una inflación que fue denunciada por
el director del instituto ofensivo
hambre cero las frutas y verduras son
también una de las cosas que los
brasileños han dejado de consumir frutas
verduras y legumbres
el tema es aún más relevante en vísperas
de las elecciones presidenciales el
gobierno acaba de decidir repartir una
ayuda del mismo valor que hace dos años
antes de la pandemia un poco más de 120
dólares que para la actualidad no
alcanzan para sobrevivir
aunque oficialmente el hambre fue
erradicado en 2014 su regreso a brasil
alarma a lara y su grupo de estudiantes
de geografía en este popular suburbio de
río cada semana preparan comida en 100
ollas para las personas en dificultad
la gente deja de comer sólo puede tener
una comida al día no es saludable los
casos de desnutrición infantil en el
país han aumentado junto con el hambre
el hambre aquí afecta primero a las
poblaciones de las periferias a la
población negra y cada vez más a madres
como gente desempleada desde el inicio
de la pandemia y con un esposo ausente
ley se lucha por alimentar a sus cuatro
hijos solo tengo este cartón de huevos
como ven no tengo nada más en la nevera
tengo que esperar a recibir mi ayuda
para poder comprar comida
pero logró comprar algo para comer esta
semana hago más de esta semana nada no
estoy esperando me ayude que llegue el
30 de cada mes para pagar algunas cosas
pagar la cuenta del gas y espero tener
suficiente para comprar alimentos por
eso dependo de la distribución de
alimentos como que hice hay muchas
mujeres en la misma situación según un
último estudio casi la mitad de las
mujeres se ven afectadas por la
inseguridad alimentaria en el país
gracias por acompañarnos en
corresponsables siga con más información
en france 24 y france 24 puntocom